[Music]
everyone hold on to your dicks next
thing I remember we are in a cab back to
this place
his mom's place my name is Carlos and I
run the world's only all-you-can-eat
naked buffet I'm sorry for spraying rat
pee in your face
ah yeah my high fives are changin dude
they're coming in hot hey no problem my
dad just died and I'm strapped for cash
so this is amazing you laser you bought
whole hair I like to use an
old-fashioned straight raise yeah I'm
not gonna take a baby's head and squeeze
it between my butt cheeks to kill it
just to clarify on camera I don't want
to I don't want to ever do that in the
TV show The Fresh Prince of bel-air I
like I like lights cannot bid more than
I like dark skin ah okay slut-shaming I
draw the line because you look at this
hamster and you know she's a any
good parent would call their kid a
I meet him and I make me do some good
point
I'm Jane and I raised braid and
slaughter gummy animals
I would kill the cat and eat it I won't
eat the cat I am NOT gonna throw my
people on the bus who could look at me
Lady Gaga and think she could play hip
hop sir
oh no I'm my mom and I'm my grandmother
and I'm alone and I'm an accordion and
I'm not on the planet that I thought I
was anymore
that's pretty good
[Music]